Let's now talk about an application of software
defined networking. Which is network virtualization. So we'll
talk first about what network virtualization is, then
we'll talk about how it's implemented. And then
we'll talk about some examples and applications, such
as Mininet. So network virtualization is simply an
abstraction of the physical network. Where multiple logical
networks can be run on the same underlying
shared physical substrate. For example, a logical network
might map a particular network topology onto the
underlying physical topology. And there might be multiple
logical networks, that map onto the same physical
topology. And these logical networks might actually share
nodes and links in the underlying physical typology.
But each logical network has its own view
as if it were running its own private version
of the network. Now you can see from
this picture, that the nodes in the physical network
need to be shared or sliced. So the
nodes in the physical typology might be virtual machines.
Similarly, a single link in the logical topology
might map to multiple links in the physical topology.
The mechanism to achieve these virtual links is
typically through tunneling. So a packet that's destined from
A to B in the logical topology, might
be encapsulated, in a packet that's destined for
node X first, before the packet is decapsulated
and ultimately sent to B. It may also
be easy to understand virtual networking as an
analogy to virtual machines, which you may be
familiar with already. So in a virtual machine
environment, we have virtual machines where a hypervisor,
arbitrates access to the underlying physical
resources. Providing to each virtual machine the
illusion that it's operating on its
own dedicated version of the hardware. Similarly,
with virtual networking, a network hypervisor
of sorts arbitrates access to the underlying
physical network, to multiple virtual networks. Providing
the illusion that each virtual network actually
has its own dedicated physical network.